ancien fief libéral outreman et depuis
2007 le château fort de thomas mulcair
ici les affiches omniprésente du chef
sont comme un rappel de sa victoire
écrasante d'il ya quatre ans douze mille
700 voix de majorité
mais par ce bon midi d'automne aux
marchés publics du chemin
côte-des-neiges
on constate que thomas mulcair n'aura
peut-être pas la victoire aussi facile
cette année de cela je ne suis pas
convaincu dans mon entourage il ya
beaucoup de gens qui kiffent avolys
trudeau oui je vote pas pour monsieur
tout doux je les aime bien en tout cas
moi c'est l'idéal
oui mais j'ai bien écouté les débats et
c'est je trouve qu'il ya de l'innovation
dans l'air bienvenue dans mon local de
campagne bienvenue dans mon comté voilà
la principale concurrente de thomas
mulcair
l'avocate rachel bnda yens moins connus
elle semble au moins avoir l'avantagé de
ne pas être associé aux femmes en niqab
même s'ils sont partis partagent la même
position que le npd thomas mulcair lui
n'y échappe pas c'est très différent de
jack layton
je sais pas c'était quoi le pignon de
jack layton sur le parc lumpini cas mais
on a des problèmes aussi des fois
l'université moi j'ai une femme qui
s'est présentée sous la tente dans mon
cours et j'ai refusé parce que sous le
niqab
oui cette professeur va voter pour le
bloc québécois
mais avant c'est que thomas mulcair est
menacée dans autrement paraît très
exagéré de lâcher cru bernard au
quartier multiethnique de côte des
neiges
le chef du npd a beaucoup de partisans à
chaque fois que j'avais des difficultés
par rapport à l'immigration juges
essayaient de prendre contact avec lui
il demander des renseignements des
conseils il était toujours disponible à
répondre la raison
patricia un petit peu un vote
stratégique mes convictions à moi c'est
pas conservateur libéral non plus en
fait là donc gentiment chaleur pour le
[ __ ] outremont sera à surveiller de plus
près le 19 octobre
ici jean sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal